[російською] Знаєте, що найцінніше у людини?
[російською] Це інвестування своїх грошей в свою освіту.
[російською] Люди, які це розуміють, йдуть до нас.
[російською] Ця найперша приватна льотна школа
була відкрита на території України в 1999 році.
[російською] Місце розташування дуже якісно впливає на освіту.
[російською] Тут нікуди піти.
[російською] Тут немає ні дискотек, ні розваг.
[російською] Навіть інтернет погано працює.
[російською] І вони тут вчаться просто від нудьги.
[російською] Їм нудно і вони вчаться.
[російською] Якщо людина прийшла сюди навчатися,
[російською] вона знає, навіщо вона прийшла і у неї все вийде.
[російською] А якщо мама з татом змусили,
це вже інший момент, як її тут змусити.
[російською] Але змушуємо.
[російською] Те, що село, нікуди не вийти,
немає дискотек і навіть АТБ — до цього веде.
[російською] Тобі нічого робити і ти просто береш і вчиш.
[російською] Іншого вибору немає.
[російською] А з іншого боку,
в авіації випадкових людей не буває.
[російською] Якщо це не твоє — не треба сюди йти.
[російською] Це навчально-тренувальний літак.
[російською] Він в змозі літати всюди,
[російською] в будь-який час,
[російською] крім складних метеоумов.
[російською] Заходить за приладами на будь-який аеродром.
[російською] Більш того, заходить в автоматичному режимі.
[російською] На ньому стоїть автопілот.
[російською] Ось аудіопанель, відповідач, радіостанція.
[російською] Три години — і він в Києві.
[російською] У нас туди навчальні польоти.
[російською] Ось це сільськогосподарський літак.
[російською] Він може взяти 400 кг вантажу.
[російською] Тим, хто вміє ним користуватися,
приносить гарну додаткову вартість.
[російською] Більше нічого в ньому особливого.
Всі літаки однакові. Двигун, гвинт, крила, фюзеляж.
[російською] Літак молодець: крутить сам гвинт.
[російською] Автопілот сильно рятує:
витримує висоту, кути атаки по ковзанню.
Попередить, якщо що.
Так, там ще тітка сидить і розповідає тобі,
правильно ти зробив чи ні. [сміються]
Англійською мовою вона все говорить.
Є така штука:
виставляємо собі певну висоту.
Для того, щоб людина орієнтувалася в цьому моніторчику,
як в грі встановлюються рамки.
Як раніше «змійкою» потрапляти потрібно було.
Так само сидиш, тільки в реальному літаку.
[російською] Від гвинта!
[російською] Сільськогосподарський,
базовий, навчально-тренувальний
[російською] і навчально-тренувальний
сільськогосподарський. У нас є чотири моделі.
[російською] Ось це основні засоби виробництва,
називаються «матриця».
[російською] У ній виготовляються різні деталі.
[російською] Весь виробничий цикл літака,
[російською] з моменту прийняття рішення до випуску,
триває шість місяців.
[російською] Але виробництво в змозі робити 4 літаки на місяць.
[російською] Сьогодні ти заклав перший літак.
[російською] Він у тебе вийде через шість місяців.
[російською] А завтра ти заклав другий літак.
[російською] І він у тебе вийде через 6 місяців і 1 день.
[російською] Літаки — це інструмент.
[російською] І якщо на них нікому літати за призначенням,
[російською] то їх купувати ніхто не буде.
[російською] А Україна літаки для приватного
використання практично не купує.
[російською] За час незалежності України
[російською] у нас зареєстровано
в приватному користуванні близько 700 літаків.
[російською] 700-800 літаків.
[російською] А в Америці щорічно продається
близько 120 тисяч літаків в приватне користування.
[російською] Тому ми і не будуємо літаки
для приватного користування.
[російською] А будуємо для сільського господарства.
[російською] І для того, щоб туди будувати,
потрібна велика кількість льотного складу.
[російською] На один проданий літак
потрібні два підготовлених пілоти.
[російською] Ось ми і займаємося підготовкою пілотів.
[російською] У мене вчився років 9 назад Соболєв.
[російською] Зараз він шеф-пілот
і екзаменатор у в'єтнамській авіакомпанії.
[російською] Зарплата там 15-20 тисяч долларів на місяць.
[російською] Ця професія соціально приваблива.
[російською] І санітарна норма 70 годин в місяць.
[російською] Ти в літаку повинен знаходитися всього 70 годин.
[російською] І тобі за це платять такі великі гроші.
[російською] Основна ціль — підготовка пілотів
на легкомоторні літаки для виконання авіахімробіт.
[російською] Тобто організувати їм нормальну кар'єру.
[російською] Щоб закінчив навчання, отримав первинну роботу,
відпрацював, набрався досвіду.
[російською] І після цього відкрита дорога у велику авіацію.
[російською] Жодна країна в світі не показує
такий темп зростання авіації, як Україна.
[російською] Жодна.
[російською] Візьмемо розвинену країну Великобританію.
[російською] Країна вже розвинена.
У них вже багато польотів.
[російською] У них вже багато аеропортів.
[російською] Вони показують відсоток зростання,
але це піввідсотка, один, можливо два.
[російською] Аеропорт Хітроу у Лондоні
третій за завантаженістю в світі.
[російською] Йому нема куди розвиватися, він величезний.
[російською] Він не зможе приймати ще більший потік людей.
[російською] У Борисполі два роки тому
було 9 мільйонів пасажирів.
[російською] У минулому році було 12 мільйонів.
[російською] 9 мільйонів щодо 12 —
за один рік це шалений відсоток.
[російською] Інформацію прийняв.
[російською] Для вашої інформації
вітер 110 градусів, 5, порив 9.
З цього місця проводяться переговори з бортами.
В даний момент в повітрі на висоті 2000 футів
над Великою Білозеркою знаходиться борт.
Доповів йому погоду,
політ спокійний, нормальний.
Присутня невелика «бовтанка».
Диспетчер бачить дані по тиску.
Вказується вітер в електронному вигляді.
А також температура і вологість.
Таких майданчиків в Україні дуже багато.
Навіть в цьому районі я знаю три,
не беручи до уваги наш діючий широківський.
Біля Малої Білозерки, Зеленого Гаю.
Раніше авіаційно-хімічні роботи були більш розвинені.
А зараз багато майданчиків
залишилися нікому не потрібними.
А мала авіація існує.
Це дуже гарне рішення для аеротаксі.
[російською] Є двигуни, які на 95-му бензині літають.
[російською] Купили 95-й бензин, приїхали, залили, полетіли.
[російською] Витрата буде приблизно такою ж, як на машині.
І це набагато безпечніше.
Безпечніше літака нічого немає.
Про те, що двигун може зупинитися,
кажуть ті, хто в цьому нічого не розуміють.
Літак вміє планувати
І у тебе залишається ще величезний запас часу,
щоб зробити певні дії.
А якщо у тебе є досвід, практика,
то це взагалі не проблема.
[російською] Тут у нас курсанти їдять.
[російською] Це камін наш.
[російською] Тут іноді собі свято влаштовуємо.
[російською] Плов готуємо, барбекю.
[російською] А курсанти живуть тут.
[російською] Тільки тихо.
[російською] Ось тут курсанти живуть.
[російською] Знаєте, як сказав Конфуцій?
[російською] Знайди роботу до душі
і ти ніколи не будеш працювати.
[російською] Так ось найбільше в цьому житті
я не люблю працювати.
[російською] Коли робиш щось в задоволення,
тоді у тебе все виходить.
[російською] Людина — егоїстичне створіння.
[російською] Вона тільки всім розповідає,
що якась правильна.
[російською] А всі ми все робимо
заради власного задоволення.
[російською] Іншого не буває.